c'est très révélateur ce qui s'est passé
ces dernières semaines depuis une
semaine précisément ce qui nous frappe
nous les équipes sur le terrain ce sont
deux mots le mot de de résilience et le
mot de combativité alors c'est très
galvaudé mais je vous assure que
lorsqu'on discute avec la population
depuis plusieurs semaines on se rend
compte à quel point l'état d'esprit a
changé depuis l'invasion le 24 février
derrière on parlait de kiffe en
introduction qui n'a pas connu de telle
frappes depuis le début de la guérilla
une semaine quand les sirènes auront
anti pendant 5 heures et que les qui
vient se sont à nouveau terrain dans des
abris anti-aériens il y a eu une panique
ce sentiment de replonger dans la guerre
alors qu'un semblant de normalité était
revenu et bien hier lorsqu'il y a eu ces
frappes de drone coordonnées dès que les
alertes ont cessé de retentir la
population est ressortie à la faveur
d'une météo clémente c'est à tablé à des
terrasses profiter du soleil et vous
voyez c'est assez révélateur de la
réaction de la population dans tout le
reste du pays il y a eu également
d'autres attaques de drones mais
également de missiles mais ce qui change
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait de cette
colère vous avez parlé de la locution de
volodières zellens qui est le soir même
il a pris la parole et ce qu'il a dit
est assez encore une fois révélateur il
dit que les dernières attaques de drones
de la Russie sont une preuve
supplémentaire qu'elle s'empêtre sur le
terrain je cite et qu'elle tente de
maquiller ses défaites militaires par la
terreur une terreur qui ne prend pas à
chaque fois que l'on discute avec ses
habitants qui nous parlent notamment de
ces morts civils cette colère ils
veulent la réemployer dans cette
contre-offensive en cours dans le Sud et
dans l'est du pays on rappelle que dans
le Sud notamment dans l'aublaste de
redsen les autorités
ukrainiennes et les forces armées de du
pays annonce avoir reconquis au moins
400 km² de territoires ils ne veulent
pas s'arrêter là ils veulent continuer
récupérer les quatre blastes dont Moscou
revendique l'annexion mais également la
Crimée qui pourrait leur objectif final